I can do the intro so hello Mr mallister
I would like to welcome you for this uh
interview and uh so to introduce you to
other people you are member of the
European Parliament you're currently in
Brussels as I'm correct and uh you are
also the chair of the Foreign Affairs
committee I would like to welcome you to
my stream hello
good morning good morning from Brussels
happy to be with you thank you very much
I have prepared a few questions and I
would like to talk about Ukraine Foreign
Affairs and things that happen in the
world so first of all there have been
multiple reports about the EU buying gas
and liquefied gas from Russia could you
explain how this situation work does the
European Union avoid sanctions or what
is actually happening in the
world since the beginning of the Russian
war of aggression against Ukraine on the
24th of February 2022 the European Union
has sanctioned the Russian Federation
now with 12 sanctions packages and the
13th sanctions package might be adopted
and one of the main aspects was that we
definitely need to bring down the amount
of the number of energy imports from
Russia that's why oil imports from
Russia have been sanctioned also gas
Imports um and we are at SU uccessful
here just to give you one number in the
third quarter of
2021 39% of our gas Import in the EU
came from Russia the third quarter of
2023 just two years later it was down to
12% so these sanctions are working but
still our energy imports from Russia are
still too high and you've mentioned an
important question energy Imports the
European Parliament has been very clear
we are calling for an overall total ban
of LNG and LPG imports from Russia and
this also includes the shipping of
Russian LNG import so we still have some
work to do this definitely needs to
change can you specify when exactly can
we expect this change so when will the
European Union ban these gases and when
will it happen so that Russia doesn't
receive our
money well we're working on this in the
end need an agreement of all 27 EU
member states some member states who are
more dependent on Russian energy Imports
are hesitant than others who are not so
dependent um of course this is also a
question of geography this is a question
of contractual commitments which we need
to respect but on the other hand we have
to be very clear we want to support
Ukraine as long as it takes and whatever
it takes and this also includes cludes
to further sanction the Russian
Federation so Russian money cannot be
used to finance this illegal war of
aggression against Ukraine so this is a
responsibility and this means that we
have to continue our work on this and
the commission is working on this matter
we need all 27 member states to agree
the European Parliament has very clearly
vo clearly made its voice here
heard um now I do not know if this
information is allowed to go public but
could you explain to us how exactly is
the legal or the negotiation process
happening between the commission and the
Parliament so how exactly do you plan to
convince those member states to join the
trialogue and actually support the
resolution so what what is the European
Union doing in this
regard well we've already adopted 12
packages of sanctions and never before
has the European Union in any any kind
of way sanctioned a third country like
the very very good and obvious reasons
we are now sanctioning the Russian
Federation the European commission has
experts who are dealing with this matter
very very skilled civil servants and
they will identify where are certain
Fields where we can put additional
pressure on the Russian Federation step
by step and the question is will there
be a 13th sanctions package if yes when
these are highly political questions and
by now you can also say that most Fields
have been identified where we can
sanction the Russian Federation anyhow
the commission experts work on this they
reach out to the 27 member states they
ask for proposals they chck their
proposals but in the end it's a
political decision that needs to be
taken all I can do as chairman of the
Foreign Affairs committee is appeal to
member states to that we continue to
show Unity our Unity is our strength and
until now the European Union has shown
remarkable unity in supporting Ukraine
on the one hand in a humanitarian way
militarily financially economically and
on the other hand putting maximum
pressure on the regime of Mr Putin thank
you very much for the answer I will move
to the second topic that I would like to
talk about and that is uh the attempt to
join Ukraine as a member of the European
Union So currently there have been
several negotiations there are also
concerns about the uh Democratic
processes with regards to Ukrainian
government what exactly is the situation
right now and what does the EU plan to
do within the upcoming
years in December the 27 heads of
government the European Council took a
historic decision to officially green
light the beginning of accession
negotiations with Ukraine
and with the Republic of
mova Ukraine is clearly on a European
Atlantic integration path Ukraine wants
to become a member of the European Union
and we are ready to support the
ukrainians just like the movans in this
endeavor of course it's a long way but
if we now decide that based on the
reports of the commission we want to
begin the negotiations this is already
acknowledging the improvements that have
been made in Ukraine despite the
incredible pressure and the challenges
because of this war of aggression
Ukraine is working on reforming the
Judiciary fighting corruption
modernizing administrative structures
and now we can begin these accession
negotiations of course becoming member
of the European Union is a long long
journey and it's very hard work and in
the end every country needs to be judged
on its own individ idual progress and
its merits the EU accession process is a
regata not a convoy and in the end a
member state has to fulfill all the
necessary conditions politically
financially economically and also
judicial wise but in this long journey
we the European Union the member states
the European commission the European
Parliament we want to give Ukraine all
the necessary
support uh could you specify if you have
the necessary information about what has
the what has the Ukrainian government
done in order to improve its situation
and uh if this is something that cannot
be currently disclosed I would like to
ask what is the long-term projection as
into how many years can we estimate for
the Ukraine to become a part of the
European
Union State can join the European Union
once this country is ready and the
European Union is ready to accept this
new member State that's why it's
difficult to predict how long this will
take and I don't think it makes much
sense to name a certain year the process
is clear the accession process means
that in the end the entire EU a key that
means the whole EU legislation needs to
be adopted and implemented in a new
member State and all the
criteria and that means the entire
criteria needs to be fulfilled
politically economically financially and
especially when it comes to Judiciary so
it's a long long journey but Ukraine is
ready to embark on this journey they
have clearly shown their commitment
towards Europe and another thing is
important for us that in the meantime
time while we are negotiating the EU
accession process of Ukraine mova and
also other countries in the western
Balkans we should step by step already
integrate them in certain structures of
the European Union that's why I'm very
much in favor of before these countries
actually join the EU but they already
invited to gradually participate in the
single Market that they gradually
participate in EU support programs so
that the citizens and the businesses
already have a benefit before finalizing
the EU membership AC process I think
this is also in our interest because we
have a responsibility to support our
partners in the western Balkans and in
Eastern Europe on their way to become a
member of the European family and a
final point the Reconstruction of
Ukraine which will be necessary and we
will support Ukraine in its
reconstruction protest should already be
organized in a way that this country is
ready to be integrated in EU
structures thank you very much for the
answer um in order for Ukraine to become
member of the European Union it has to
at least somehow win the war or succeed
in their fight against Russia um
currently the European Union is
supplying both humanitarian and uh just
offensive weapons uh my question would
be has the European Union considered
supplying stronger weapons such as
longrange uh Cru missiles or any kind of
new Advanced
military
equipment the brave Ukrainian women and
men are not only defending their own
country and their own liberty and their
own Freedom they are defending the
European peace and security architecture
there so much at stake in this war and
that's why EU member states NATO allies
and others we are supporting ukra
Ukraine in their right to defend their
country against this brutal war of
aggression of the Russian Federation
against the Ukrainian
people we have said that we will support
Ukraine as long as it takes that was a
good decision but it's also about giving
Ukraine what the ukrainians need to
successfully conduct their military
operations
and that's why what the brave Ukrainian
soldiers need most desperately are
weapon and ammunition and that's why we
call as European Parliament on our
member states to step up the production
of ammunition to step up the production
of weapons and to deliver what the
ukrainians need the European Union
itself doesn't have ammunition or
military capabilities we don't have
weapons in our depos but we can
Finance to buy weapons and ammunition
what we are doing through the European
peace facility for the first time and we
call on our member states to give what
they can give and this includes also
from my point of view the most
sophisticated missiles what the
ukrainians desperately need to uh attack
the Russian support lines
thank you very much uh we're currently
in let's say a half of our interview so
I would like to move to let's say a
second field of topics and that is uh
questions about other countries and
Foreign Affairs that are happening
considering Europe so one of the things
that is happening is that a lot of
European members or members of the
European Union are trading with China as
you probably know China is both a
competitor to the European Union Ura
Wonder lion uh was addressing their
issue with subsidizing their markets my
question would be what is the limitation
with regards to both human rights and
economic intervention at which the
European Union would stop trading with
China and impose sanctions similar to
Russia in dealing with China I would
always follow the free English seas that
means the EU China relationship ship
should be coined under the free
points cooperate where
possible compete where needed confront
when necessary and as you said China for
us is many things in one China is a
cooperation partner for instance on
climate change but on the other hand
China is a
competitor China has a strong economy
just like we do but what we need is a
free and Fair competition with China we
need a Level Playing Field especially
for our small and medium-sized
businesses in Europe which they don't
have at the moment on the Chinese market
but China is also a geopolitical
rival China has very different views
than we do when it comes to human rights
when it comes to the freedom of speech
to civil rights within China but China
is also a very assertive place
on the global uh arena in the global
Arena and we make very clear to our
Chinese counterparts the international
rules-based order needs to be defended
and protected because only the
international rules-based order defends
medium and small siiz countries against
the bullies we also call on China to
strengthen multilateral corporation
which is very uh important for us in
Europe but also in the United States so
what what is the solution we need to
readjust our relations with China we
don't want to have a confrontation with
China but we have to make very clear
where we stand and I think it's very
important in dealing with China you need
to be principled in your political
positions and in your values and we need
to decrease the
dependencies with and of China that also
means that what we need to do is not to
decouple economically we want to
interact with China economically it's
about drisking we need to reduce the
risks in dealing with China and that's
why we have put some legislation forward
in recent years I would always mention
the European chips act or the European
raw materials act we need to diversify
our supply chains we need to decrease
the dependencies um with
China understandable thank you very much
I would like to ask about the principle
that you've mentioned so we need to
focus our cooperation or the the
interactions with China based on certain
levels um the question I would ask is
for many people from the Generation Z My
Generation uh it is important that China
follows uh not only International laws
but also doesn't breach human principles
or human rights when it comes to Chinese
extremes or what they have been doing
with regards to ugur or the risks
associated with Taiwan um what is the
limitation or the principal stance when
it comes to the European Union and uh
when would it say this is too much we
need to confront rather than
cooperate the European Union especially
the European Parliament we are staunch
Defenders of Human Rights all over the
world human rights count globally and we
want to promote we want to support we
want to defend human rights not in
Europe but all over the world including
in China and that's why we have been
principled in our
messages to the Communist Party
leadership in Beijing that the human
rights situation in China is Dia and
that we have very very different views
on how to deal with citizens you
mentioned the fate of the yugar for me
that is the most systematic violation of
Human Rights over such a long period of
time we have seen in the last decade
so yes we have very different views of
the Chinese Communist party uh in China
how what can we do I think we need to be
principled and we are our strength as
European Union is that we are an
economic power we are an economic
superpower this is where we can actually
play a role and I would always say that
those who want to do business with
Europe vote who are more on our side
when it comes to defending important
values and princi principles should be
able to do more and better business with
us than others this is the best way we
can gain influence and of course apart
from that we have to be clear in our
political positions in the United
Nations in international fora wherever
we are together with Chinese we need to
address these matters and what I have
learned in dealing with Chin Chinese is
the more self-confident you are the more
principled you are the more respect you
might find and the more you might listen
to thank you very much for the answer uh
I also would like to ask about the
relations that European Union has with
other countries particularly USA uh the
upcoming elections are happening not
only in European Union but also America
where they have to choose their new
president and there is a risk or at
least for me personally it is a risk of
Donald Trump winning his candidacy now
of course uh European Union has to be
political with regards to trying to deal
with different uh presidents or
different politicians uh what is the
approach that the European Union is
going to take after the elections
regardless of whether Biden or Trump
wins well we'll waiting for the US
elections on the 5th of November and it
will be up to the American people to
decide who their next president will be
if there will be another term from Mr
Biden or if Mr Trump might get the
possibility of re-entering the White
House we can't decide this we will have
to wait and for the decision of the
American people but we as European Union
need to be prepare for both outcomes of
the election uh the United States are
our most important Ally and partner the
United Nations is the key Ally in NATO
and NATO protects our Liberty our
freedom in Europe so the US is the
security provider for us in Europe
that's why we have a huge interest in
maintaining excellent transatlantic
relations and the United States is also
by far our most important economic
partner our most important trade partner
so whatever the next us Administration
will look like I would always advise Our
member states and the European Union to
reach out to identify people on both
sides of the aisle in the Congress
Republicans Democrats to work on
strengthening transatlantic relations
the first four years of Mr Trump in
office in the White House were a bumpy
ride for us in the European Union we
know that Mr Trump is often
unpredictable in his policies uh he has
been unpredictable in talking about the
transatlantic Alliance uh we had some
hiccups when it comes to trade we had
him questioning uh the Article Five
obligation NATO he was also uh talking
about withdrawing United States troops
from the European Union so we know from
the first four years that it was a bumpy
term but bumpy ride but let's wait and
see first of all it's the American
people who will decide on the 5th of
November and I think it's fair to say
that many many people in Europe will be
keeping their fingers crossed for one
candidate I understand thank you very
much uh with regards to again other
countries and the Affairs happening in
the world I would assume your work has
to be quite tough because of all the
different things that are happening uh
one of the recent ones is the conflict
between Israel and Palestine so what is
the current European Union stance on the
matter because of the icj so
International court of justice ruling uh
that Israel has
to do as much as possible to prevent
genocide in um in Gaza does the European
Union believe that Israel has been
committing genocide or what is the
principled stance that the EU has been
taking you were asking about the
European Union's position on this War uh
first of all the European Union
recognizes that Israel has a legitimate
right of
self-defense after this outrageous
horrific terrorist attack of the 7th of
October Israel is fighting a war against
the terrorist organization Hamas and
Israel is fighting this war but Israel
of course is obliged to respect
international law an international
humanitarian law the European Parliament
has called for a ceasefire but under two
very important conditions the first one
all hostages need to be released all
hostages
immediately and
second Hamas structures need to be
totally dismantled there cannot be a
future for the Gaza Strip with Hamas
that's our first position our second
position has always been the European
Union supports a two-state solution with
Israel and Palestine as two independent
states living next to each other uh and
we follow we we support the policy of
reconciliation we would see Jerusalem as
the joint capital of these two states uh
we should be starting to implement
concrete reforms on this recent
reconciliation path
now when it comes to the situation in
Gaza I mean the humanitarian situation
is just a catastrophe in Gaza far too
many people have been killed the
civilian population is suffering and
they are suffering under the war on the
one hand but they're also suffering
because Hamas is using civilians as
human protection Shields against Israeli
military
operations when it comes to unra the
European Union is by far the largest
donor of financial support to the
Palestinians we are proud of that but we
call on the International Community to
also uh engage more and supporting the
Palestinians but the allegations the
accusations against the unra people now
is so outrageous there needs to be a
thorough and comprehensive investigation
into this matter the people responsible
need to be uh need to take the
appropriate consequences for their
horrible actions
uh not a scent of European taxpayers
money should be used and must be used to
finance Terror we are very clear as
European Parliament that's why in the
next plenary week in Strasburg we will
debating these recent outrageous
allegations against unra staff and we
will also have in my foreign affairs
committee together with the development
cooperation committee we will also have
a briefing and an exchange of views with
representative of un what actual
consequences is this organization now
taking yeah uh thank you very much my
last question would be also about the
icj ruling so the prevention of genocide
in Gaza as you have mentioned yourself
the humanitarian situation is
catastrophic uh how exactly can the
European Union at this point help to
prevent any further damages any further
destruction uh is there any attempt to
either negotiate with Israel or the
government of Netanyahu to accept a
two-state solution or what exactly will
the European Union do in this
matter on the one hand the European
Union are member states were all working
uh around our diplomatic channels trying
to find a solution that the killing of
innocent civilians can stop I have
mentioned uh for instance the proposal
of the European Parliament for a
ceasefire but with the conditions which
need to be met on the other hand what
the European Union is doing is that we
are giving support to the people to the
civilians we are supporting the
Palestinian people who are suffering uh
under uh these military actions and by
the way we are giving
also Financial humanitarian support to
the people of Gaza who have suffered for
so long under the
regime of these criminal terrorists of
Hass thank you very much for the answer
uh I think we're going to the end or or
heading to the end of our interview uh
thank you for joining I hope you have a
really good day and with regards to both
your committee your votes and everything
else that you have to do in Brussels
thank you for hosting me and uh have a
lovely
day thank you all the best from Brussels
of course
goodbye
all